in the last episode of our series we
were introduced to a spectacular
elongated skull from parakas peru
it has been claimed by
websitegaia.com that these skulls are 25
larger in volume than normal human
skulls
because gaia is a website that charges
10 a month to learn more we suspect that
they might be misleading the public in
order to make money here we will conduct
an experiment to see how good humans are
at judging volume by eye
you are watching episode 2 of citizen
science versus the aliens of peru
okay jackson
tell the good people of the internet
what we've got going on here this little
experiment we're going to be doing on
them
now this is an experiment to see
uh which cup
is more full
and which one is what has less
right
so what what i did actually when jackson
wasn't even looking
as i filled these all up with 400
milliliters of water what is a
milliliter
uh
you've made a rough design of it didn't
you yeah a milliliter is a cubic
centimeter so if you imagine a
centimeter the cube made out of a
centimeter oh
one milliliter is the same as one cubic
centimeter and there are 400 cubic
centimeters in each one of these cups
now the cups are different shapes just
like these two skulls
are different shapes
and human beings are super bad at
judging volume that is how much space
something takes up we're super bad at
judging with our eyes and because of
that conspiracy theorists
they'll look at this and say oh it's an
alien because it looks bigger than this
normal skull but really it's because
they're bad at judging volume with their
eyes that's actually what's going on so
what we did is we i filled all these
with 400 milliliters of water
then i took 40 milliliters this is 40
milliliters right here
i took 40 milliliters out of one of them
and then i poured that into one of the
other ones
so one of these cups is missing 40
milliliters and one of these cups has an
extra 40 milliliters now just so you
know the coloring here has nothing to do
with anything i i did the coloring
afterwards so
um don't use that as a hint
but
one of these is missing 40 milliliters
and one of them has
too many 40 extra milliliters but before
we do the experiment jackson we've made
a mistake
we are trying to teach people stuff on
the internet but we are not dressed up
like scientists when they watch their
conspiracy theory shows on tv
all the people are dressed up like
scientists they're usually not
scientists
like people like jaime
he's one of the alien conspiracy guys
he'll be on tv all dressed up in a white
lab coat he looks all crazy they don't
care that the the information is given
is bad they just accept it because he's
wearing a white lab coat what are we
doing jackson
we need white lab coats
do you have
we should go to target and buy some
should we yeah we could just buy them
anywhere we want they sell them all over
the place they even sell white lab coats
to anyone you don't need a degree
nothing they'll sell you white lab coats
at any drugstore
so
let's go let's go get our
magical science scare on all right three
two
one
what the heck
how did you do that
i think that we might be a little bit
this might be a little bit overkill what
do you think yeah if you ask me it looks
a little overkill yeah let's lose the
mask yeah
maybe that maybe the head [ __ ] should i
keep the glasses or the glasses cool the
glasses i'm supposed to wear anyway so
all right
they're fine all right we are now
official scientists so
all right
ladies and gentlemen here's the
experiment i want you to guess
which one of these
is fuller which one is less full
and this is number one
two three four five six seven eight nine
in the youtube comments write less
equals and then choose your number
and then write more equals and then
choose your number pretty simple
which one
is more full which one is less full
we're going to find out the answer
next week
make sure to subscribe to our channel so
you catch that when it comes out
can you get both right
or at least one rate or at least one
we'll give you
a b minus we'll give you a b minus
if you get it right we'll give you your
prize is the joy of being right
on the internet
should we give them a reward
jackson wants to give you a free school
from bone clones with his allowance
no i only have one book
okay
all right so next week we will find the
answer until then
stay curious all right high five
[Music]
you